a defining vote and a defining moment
for mep peter lisa earlier this year
parliament's environment committee voted
through amendments to legislation on
europe's co2 emissions trading system
in effect more broadly covering aviation
emissions
but who is it who guides laws along the
obstacle-strewn pathways of
parliamentary procedure
step up mr lisa as the reporter the
rapporteur needs to create a united
parliament's position
and then broker an agreement with the
council and commission you need first of
all to know a lot on the file so to
understand
what it's about
you need to listen to many many people
also from outside the parliament from
industry environmental ngos other
stakeholders and then
you need to work to bring people
together so the rapporteur is a lead
pitcher for meps and chief backstop for
parliament but he or she is not alone
stand up and be recognized the shadow
rapporteur the rapporteur him or herself
always of course represents one
political group and other political
groups nominate the shadows to negotiate
on behalf of their respective groups so
that's the team well balanced across the
political groups
what's next
rapporteur's raw material comes in the
shape of a legislative proposal drawn up
by the european commission a regulation
or a directive it's rarely perfect i've
never experienced that i supported a
commission proposal just as it was
presented we always work on amendments
and the final agreement is always
different different in this case it's
completely different the biggest
conflict was
between the public interest
to to protect
us from worsening climate change and the
business interest of the airlines they
have been also very much lobbying uh
european governments so that european
governments have been willing to
weaken
the current legislation next stop after
those agreement between all the groups
are negotiations with member states a
process known as trilog in which the
rapporteur can find him or herself up
against entrenched views
we had a very
strong position from the council
not willing to accept any
movement of course we couldn't accept
this you know we are there to negotiate
and not to just accept the council's
position and in the end they moved for
the socialist shadow rapporteur matthias
grota there was a red line beyond which
this file would not get his group
support redirecting the money raised
through the auction of co2 aviation
emissions we want an earmarking because
we want to spend the money we collect
from the emissions which we are emitted
by the by the
evasion sector to fight climate change
for adaptation things and so on mr lisa
acknowledges that because of the need
for compromise inside and outside the
parliament mep's legislative ambitions
may be watered down nonetheless he says
advances have been made step by step and
that's the way european politics work